nice
you dropped the whole path of solder to
me what did you do you messed it up
why stop it every time
all right i'm back with part two of the
series that nobody asked for
last time we did this i tried making a
traditional korean meal for the very
first time
and it was quite the journey i've always
wanted to improve my skills and learn
more about other cultures so
this week i've asked my best friend
andrew to send me his mom's best haitian
recipe
and we'll see how well this turns out
all right
[Music]
i know i asked you for your mom's best
haitian recipe
give it to me what is it uh so what i
sent you specifically was lydia
which is kind of like a vegetable stew
poured over rice it's a green medley and
people throw anything in there from beef
to chicken the pork
and because you're from maryland i sent
you to crab one so
oh wait they have a crab one okay i can
rock with that
wait so where do i get the crab from
where do i buy the crab
no it's like a whole crack wait like i
cooked the crab myself
you got this you got this i got this
positive energy
all right i got i do got this but uh
just in case send me your mom's phone
number
we're at the grocery store but we're
going to go in and try our best to find
everything so
let's do it
you know what that says what is that
watercress watercress
no i don't think they have a crowd don't
think we have crabs
i see one crab we could do is that good
enough
andrew i just spent 107 better enjoy
this meal
it is currently 8 30 in the morning i
want to go back to bed
but hey i've got bills to pay what
what it's the real me today we're making
the
crab legume got my apron
cut your cats baby let's get it
all right first thing we're gonna do is
cook these crabs thankfully i think
they're dead
oh my god
hey this is a great mixtape cover
i'm not too sure how to cook crabs
actually so
i'm going to call my lifeline today mom
saying chest
here we go
hello honestly josh i don't know how to
cook this crab
okay so i need your help okay you have
to take a big knife we can cut this crab
in four
something maybe you're fine on the
middle go ahead are you scared of the
i'm pretty scared i'm not gonna i'm
pretty scared all right you know i'm
just gonna go for it i'm just gonna go
for it yeah just go for it go for it
good job smash it one more time one time
the knife will come out
okay um i got this uh
kansas city inspired rub
what
you're gonna put a little bit of salt a
little bit of black pepper
all right a little bit of salt a little
bit
what did you do you messed it up yeah a
little bit
so how important is this uh dish in
haitian culture
in haitian culture usually we don't use
spinach we use something that called
lalo it's very slimy it's a green
leaves but it's very very good for you
what do you think is the most important
ingredient the seasoning
oh love thank you so much mama saying
just
i'll talk to you later all right so
after taunting andrew's mom
i feel a lot better i feel good sun is
shining let's get this legume baby
[Music]
we're gonna put the lid on top set it to
low
and let it simmer for 45 minutes while
we listen to black pink
in yo area
all right it's been 45 minutes you are
in the shot
my good sir get out of the shot all
right
all right it's been 45 minutes this
thing has been boiling away let's see
what it looks like
all right all he said in the recipe was
the green will get dark if you boil it
i mean it looks dark all right the thing
i'm concerned about is like
it's still like soupy all right i'm just
gonna let this go for 10 more minutes
and then
we'll check it one more time after a
quick commercial break
[Music]
round three baby hopefully this is the
one
why is this so soupy it's just like
straight water
let me call andrew real quick
is this supposed to be like soupy
no it's supposed to be like um big chili
honestly it looks like it looks just
like spinach soup at this point
[Music]
almost crank it up
yeah it tastes good don't matter all
right
i'll make it taste alright that's all
that matters right
all right i'll talk to you later
[Music]
huh i feel like he just needs more of
everything
all right there's a lot more salt some
black pepper
shut up just a little bit oh my god i
think it's missing something
oh this is it this is it
yeah i'm gonna get rosa in the comments
i can already tell oh yeah
oh yeah all right look i know it's not
super authentic but this
looks good it smells good
if i say so myself i killed it
[Music]
i like to make some minor adjustments
but at least it tastes good
i'm gonna pack this up send it over to
andrew and we'll see what he thinks
all right just got the box it feels a
little heavy so
i think you packed a bunch it might be a
good amount of food all right but let's
see all right i see the crab up front
let's see the crab right here yeah are
you
everybody's hungry all right upon
initial inspection it it does
look really good i'm not even gonna lie
to you the smell kind of hit me in my
nose i like that i'm really with it
let's warm it up it's frozen let's see
what we got
here i'm a man of my word i told you
right
i will say all those aside it looks the
part
all right so here we go
okay okay i'll give you a solid seven
oh i'll take it i'll take it
the seasoning was surprisingly good it
probably needs a little bit more salt
describe the flavor for me what are you
tasting like peppery salty what are you
tasting
i i'm tasting a little bit of
a smoky a savory savory
like savory sweet smoky
like from the kansas city inspires his
thing
you put this in this book
what did i say i told you it's good
right it's good
i told you i changed my ratings my
rating is
honestly girl you went grocery shopping
you talked to my mom i know you've been
trying to like expand your cooking to
other cultures and stuff
and i feel like for your first attempt
it was definitely solid bro
six thumbs up all right i'll take it
i'll take it be honest
will you expect to find this in your in
your pantry
anytime soon no no
don't disrespect
[Music]
you